while the uncharted movie largely charts
its own path with an original story
different to the games there are a
handful of easter eggs and game
references for eagle-eyed fans to keep a
lookout for and not only that but it
features a post-credit sting that teases
a sequel that might actually follow the
games a lot more closely let's dig into
it all biggest treasure that's never
been found five billion easy
for starters let's talk about sam
drake's role in the uncharted movie
which is actually pretty minimal for the
entirety of the movie he's awol but his
influence is felt throughout some key
moments
that's right up until the very last
scene before the credits here we see a
grimy looking prison with a man
scribbling away furiously and some
postcards addressed to nathan drake and
while it's not explicitly stated who
this mysterious person is i'd put a
whole load of money on it being sam
drake and this sort of mirror is what we
see in uncharted 4 as well where sam is
left half dead in a panamanian jail
although it's yet to be seen if this is
also the case in the movie world and if
you want to get more information or
maybe just a quick reminder about what
happens to sam in the games make sure to
check out our complete uncharted
timeline that we've got up on the
channel right now
right let's break down that short post
credit sting that sets up a potential
sequel this short scene takes place
roughly halfway through the credits so
at least you don't need to sit through
them all in it we see nate and sully
meet with a shady looking eye patch
sporting pilo aspect who played euron
greyjoy from game of thrones and they're
discussing their potential next big job
which sully says could be the big one
there's mention of a nazi treasure map
and another character simply called
roman both of which are pretty solid
references to the very first game in the
franchise uncharted drake's fortune it
looks like drake and our german pals
were after the same treasure and i've
got the map that's going to lead us
right to it
in that game nate sully and elena fisher
nate's future wife search for the lost
treasure of el dorado and encounter
among other things a nazi u-boat in the
jungle as well as a german u-boat
station in a race against rival treasure
hunter gabriel roman potentially the
roman whose name checked in this scene
friends of yours sully
and gabriel roman yeah i know who you
are [ __ ]
manners young man this is just business
beyond all those teases for a future
adventure in the movie universe we get a
handful of little easter eggs to other
games in the franchise most notably
sully sporting a mustache which he sadly
doesn't for the entirety of the movie
what is that thing on your face yeah
puberty's right around the corner kids
you can grow your own not only that but
we see sully in a very colorful outfit
more in keeping with his character's
stylish wardrobe from the games and
lastly we see nate himself in a long
sleeve top very similar to the one drake
wears in the columbia sequences from
uncharted 3. another little visual nod
to the source material
regardless of all those neat little
easter eggs we're just gonna have to
wait and see if sony actually bankroll a
sequel to this movie so the lads can go
on that next big adventure i'm hoping
that sully's cat's gonna be along for it
either way what's with the cat she's
just real what the life seems super sad
i'm not gonna keep this thing
right let's dig into some of the key
references to the games that the movie
has i mean if you've seen the trailers
you'll know that the film features a
fair few set pieces from the games most
notably it's central action sequence on
brad xplain
this whole sequence is lifted nearly
directly from uncharted 3 with a couple
of little tweaks to the action firstly
drake chloe and sully are all aboard the
plane in the movie version as opposed to
just nate in the game and they smuggle
themselves aboard in the trunk of
santiago's red car instead of the
dramatic and action-packed way it
happens in the game
and secondly they're not flying over the
desert they're over a series of islands
in the seas near indonesia so when nate
crashes to earth in one of those
containers he lands in the water and
doesn't get stranded in the rhubal khali
perfect another sequence that takes its
cues from the games is the auction set
piece which takes place relatively early
on here nate and sully are after a
golden cross that acts as a key to their
next clue and this set piece feels
incredibly reminiscent of a similar
scene in uncharted 4 a thief's end where
nate sully and nate's brother sam are
trying to lift a similar item from a
similar auction nate's even tasked with
cutting the power in both sequences we
are going once
going twice
then i shall sell it for 500 000 and
ladies and gentlemen please remain calm
beyond that there's a handful of visual
references to the games in an early
sequence we see a young drake yeah even
younger than tom holland with his
brother sam during their time at the
saint francis orphanage and this scene
takes a fair few cues from the young
drake scenes from uncharted 4 also set
at the same orphanage and later on we
see nate with a trunk from saint
francis's with a load of his old stuff
from sam and chief among it all is
francis drake's ring which appears
prominently throughout the game series
this was francis drake's ring i you know
kind of inherited it sick harvest magna
greatness from small beginnings it was
his motto and in a blink and you'll miss
it cameo there's a sticker in nate's
trunk that is the same image as naughty
dog's paw print logo
[Music]
a quick word on the movie's adaptation
of some of the franchise's key
characters and their origins obviously
we're introduced to the central duo of
nathan drake and sully but the origin of
their meeting is changed quite
drastically from how it's portrayed in
the games when nate is still a teenager
and meets a much older sully while
pickpocketing him in colombia look you
got talent
but you got a lot to learn
you stick with me and i'll teach you a
few things
in the movie though sully finds nate and
persuades him to help in his hunt for
the treasure of ferdinand magellan and
it's revealed that sully is approaching
nate after sam drake has gone missing
working the same job and then there's
chloe fraser who first crops up in the
games in uncharted 2 and in this movie
she plays a somewhat similar role in the
game she flits between friend and foe to
drake even though she's ultimately more
of an ally and we see this same dynamic
in the movie too albeit in a slightly
more cutthroat way where she could
potentially be set up to be a future
sequel's antagonist but for fans of the
game there's one central cameo that will
really get them all nostalgic and that's
one nolan north the original voice and
mocap actor behind the game's version of
nathan drake after the central plane
sequence nate and chloe find themselves
at a luxury resort in indonesia and as
they're wading up from the waves they
bump into none other than nolan north
sunbathing on the beach he even gets a
few choice lines and after nate explains
that they got there via crashing out of
a plane north references that something
similar happened to him once upon a time
and the whole scene is underscored by
the original uncharted theme on the
soundtrack just to really sell the
nostalgia
right that's those tantalising
post-credit scenes explained and all the
game references and easter eggs that i
could spar if i missed anything please
let me know in the comment section down
below and make sure to subscribe because
we've got a ton of uncharted content on
the channel right now so make sure to
check that out too thanks for watching
guys i'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you